[音楽]
今日から twitter 読むか今日からついた羊毛スリッパのサイズだってね
はじめちゃん再放送してた
本当だあってねー骨じゃあ肇社長です皆さんパソコン使うことありますけどほなの皆
さん使っていると思うんですけど
パソコンでパソコンでもず打ち込むときにキーボードが必要なんですよ
k バーと6つ com なんでー
フライ自分の子だよもうキーボードなってくるんですよ
こちらああ
[拍手]
[音楽]
なんだっけ
まずえっとえっとレーザーレーザーで上場にキーボードがないんですけども仮想の
キーボードを作り出す機械新字体でございますこれちょっと受けてみましょうか
はいっ
を夜爪所が入ってますねほいもうこんな小さいんだ
いやお前はねーっ
めちゃくちゃ wi-fi とバスだけど皆さんこれが住んじゃいのキーボードなん
ですわ
わけわかんないでしょうちょっとねほんとあの実際見てみないとわかんないんですが
しっかりと旧ベロついてますねキーボードってきていくね場所を取るんですよね103
がその abcd とがアルファベットとかなヤジの人が全部色々書いてあるこの絶対
キー坊がもう時代的な古いなんか場所を取るなということで最新時代はそんな
キーボードのスペースを吐く
キーコから創製されるこのレーザーにキーボードを作り出せてそれを押す打ち込める
らしいんですよ
fe 本当だったらマジ梅組ですよこれからなんだろうと日本語は書いてないですね
a なんか
ぐらいにめちゃくシミがついてるんですけどちょっと怪しいなんかパチ化パッチの可能
性もあるんちょっとそんな信用しないままちょっと1回使ってみようと思いますそれ
だけぽさを増していきます
go
ってけどキーボードだってこれがサイトってたんですけど阿蘇取りますよねやっぱり
ポンドスマートにパソコンの作業をしたい人多いと思うんでこんな場所にこんな場所に
もホログラフィックでキーボードを作り出せるらしいんですよねこれを使うとどういう
子っていうかわかんないんですけどこれじっくり漬け込みますか
usb で版で着くと雰囲気は常に下ボタン押しますはい
入った
なんか点滅してこれを
エイ
日
的にまだご存知しこれが他のあるん
ついたついた見え見えますこんなに入っ
[音楽]
つい最近初めてことで動いてんなでこれまでこれから音出てんだけどどういうすみだ
これず皆さん見えます姫ボード時出るんですよ
ポスト反応するとこれ見にくいらしくって言ってしますうわぁマックやにすると結構
みえますねー
を聞かれ全員がもっと大きく受けそうだなこれ見ても俺の体がキーボードになっちゃう
よこれ9 t もないで言ってことを次へこれ壁もキーボードで打ってことこれ
山王あるはいえー
できた者できた俳優と綺麗に全部キーボード
なってますねー
すごい問題は実用的かどうかですよね打ち込んでみます
[音楽]
反応性なんだろうねうんえっ
バッハ
あ
おおぅふ10代だけでは撃ちますねちょっとっ
女性プールにはじめさちょっと行きます
西ん
めっちゃ呉汁んですよ反応だったでああいうことですね
はいもう議会絶対1回して抑えも言いますよ
あっっ
はいアブ出てればな判断はちょっと遅いかすんだよなぁ
あぴっく
ほらもうなんかば発売さになるんですよねこれ何
あ
ちょっと家のはやっぱり遅いなーすげー2タイプ見せしちゃいます
ん
これもう重ねた数え茶や薄着すぎな感覚ですね付をタッチしてるだけでも違って
るっていう
移しな感覚なんですけど
明るいところで何も見えんどこがどうなるかもよくわからないんでまずちょっとマジ
きつい
こっちはいいや
[音楽]
うっはうスムーズ天井大きいほどてるよこれ
ん
使えんな